[Music]
what's interesting to me is we will use
ai
as we have been to specifically target
tasks that we need or want done in place
of ourselves
that's how ai will ultimately unfold
it is a renaissance it is a golden age
we are now solving problems with machine
learning and artificial intelligence
that were you know kind of in the realm
of science fiction for the last several
decades
ai is probably the most important thing
humanity has ever worked on
i think of it as something more profound
than electricity or
fire and anytime you work with
technology
you need to learn to harness the
benefits and while minimizing the
downside
is we're focusing on autonomous systems
and clearly one purpose of autonomous
systems is
self-driving cars there are others uh
and we sort of see it as the mother of
all ai projects
there's a class of things like game
plane
or speech recognition or image
recognition
that the performance levels are
phenomenal
you know if you compare human speech
recognition computer speech recognition
the computer is slightly better and
that's you know
mind-blowing certainly we use ai to do
drug discovery these biological systems
are very complicated
and so the fact that we have vaccines
for tb
and hiv coming that's partly enabled by
this rich data
advance in biology and machine learning
when i look at seeing ai which is an
application we just launched for anybody
with visual impairment they can go
download this app that uses the latest
cutting edge computer vision technology
in our cloud to give anyone
the ability to see and in fact angela
mills was a colleague of mine was just
telling me about how it's changed her
life
inside of microsoft she can go into our
cafeteria order food using this app with
confidence
walk into conference rooms with
confidence because she knows she's
walking into the right conference room
or what we've done with our onenote and
word learning tools
anyone who has dyslexia can now use ai
to be able to read better
the latest release of windows 10 has
this capability called eye gaze
which is something that we learned
working with steve gleason and the als
patients saying if you all you have is
the
eye muscle and the gaze can we help you
type
yeah you have to be careful when there's
advances in a sense
we're all better off if the machines can
make all the food and the clothes
and none of us have to work uh and you
think okay now we have all the freedom
if we want to stand behind the
the counter and you know make sandwiches
okay you can
if you want but there's this other way
to make those goods and services
but it will be very disruptive because
you know say your mid-career
in manufacturing or driving then it's a
disruption
now we've had that in a slow way for
hundreds of years
you know we used to all be farmers now
very few of us are farmers
i said it's right to be concerned
absolutely you have to worry about it
otherwise you're not going to solve it
right
and it's important to understand
tomorrow whether google is there or not
you know artificial intelligence is
going to progress
uh you know technology has this nature
it's going to evolve i think pulling
back
history shows pulling back countries
which pull back
don't do well with the change we know
that
20 30 years ago you educated yourself
and that carried you through for the
rest of your life
that is not going to be true for the
generation which is being born now
they have to learn continuously over
their lives we know that
so we have to transform how we do
education
look i think i mean you nailed it
anything that's repetitive and done
you know on the back of you know
technology or you know
is going to be fundamentally vulnerable
yeah so i think
technology in particular ai can in fact
bring
more empowerment more inclusiveness and
at the same time we should be clear-eyed
about displacement clear-eyed about
unintended consequences like any other
technology
and work both skilling so that
you know people can find the jobs of the
future
create new jobs and lastly
i think have a set of policy decisions
that really help people
as they go through this change
[Music]
the risks are important and i think the
way we solve it is
we think ahead we worry about it we
do things like from from be upfront
you know have ethical charters think
about ai safety from day one
be very transparent and open in how we
perceive progress there
and figure out global frameworks by
which we can engage just like paris
agreement and climate change
you know using forums like this i think
we bring people together
to engage on the hard questions and i
think ansys will emerge
you know i i have exposure to the very
most cutting edge
um ai um uh
and i think people should be really
concerned about it
um i keep sounding the alarm bell but
you know until people see like robots
going down the street
killing people like they don't know how
to react you know because it seems so
ethereal
um and um i think we should be really
concerned about
ai and i think we should
this ai is a rare case where i think we
need to be proactive in regulation
instead of reactive because i think by
the time
we are reactive in ai regulation it's
too late
right now we have machine learning
algorithms that
can solve an incredibly complex problem
beyond any human intelligence but
they're essentially
complete idiots and like two-year-olds
and anything that's not that problem
they're dumb
they're like that you can give them this
enormous data set
and they come up with brilliant
correlations and insights but they're
not going to
plug into skynet and you know like like
like threaten us anytime soon
so i'm quite optimistic and
i don't think artificial intelligence
is a threat i don't think that if at
fish intelligence is something
terrible but human beings are smart
enough to learn that
[Music]
you